welcome back to new rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and Rick and Morty season 4 episode
3 one crew over the crew coos bored II
will forever change the way you watch
Ocean's eleven or Inception you son of a
[ __ ] but why does Rick hate heists so
much is this episode masking a deeper
conspiracy to reprogram us to hate the
Marvel Cinematic Universe I programmed
you to roll your eyes welcome to I
explained our Rick and Morty after show
where we dive deep into the hidden
agenda of each episode with special
guests and share some hot takes that
everyone agrees with the title one crew
over the crew coos Morty is a take on a
novel in film One Flew Over the Cuckoo's
Nest which isn't technically a heist
story but it does feature a crew of
eccentrics plot II and a creative
breakout from a mental hospital really
the target of this episode are heist
films like the oceans series inception
the Thomas Crown Affair The Italian Job
in which Connor tis sleekly subvert and
outsmart in a series of exhaustive
reveals that everything we've been
seeing is part of an elaborate planned
facade all set to cool jazzy heist music
it's also worth noting that two of the
biggest films of 2019 were heist movies
Avengers end game which featured its
infinity stone time ice and spider-man
far from home in which Mysterio uses
implausible illusions to trick Peter
Parker with insane reveal after insane
reveal in order to iced away his magical
sunglasses which is pretty similar to
how heist a Tron and Rick out reveal
each other over two hours conveniently
the average length of a film will not
end game that was infinity hours
Rick and Morty Koch creator Dan Harmon
hates high stories he dismisses them as
hackery because they trick audiences
into thinking they're seeing clever
writing but really they're just
impossibly smart characters needlessly
complicated a simple theft with layers
upon layers of Lies without any
emotional growth yes Rick's disdain for
the highest honor is absolutely based on
mine yeah I don't think you should make
episodes based on your hatred of
something whatever man like I'm I just
think it's ironic that the heist genre
steals so much money from culture this
isn't even the first time Rick and Morty
has trashed this kind of storytelling
season 1 episode 4 M night Sumerians
featured a similar plot with a race of
alien scammers who trap people in
simulations to get them to reveal their
secrets
there are simulations within simulations
within simulations like the dream within
a dream within a dream heist of
Inception and each simulation is
revealed as an annoying gotcha
until Rick just blows them all up Dan
Harmon has also mocked the conspiracy
twist plot trope in an episode of his
sitcom community season 2 episode 9
conspiracy theories and interior design
in which Jeff fabricates a night course
that he says he's taking just weren't
really when he made up but it ends up
kind of being real or does it it goes
back and forth back and forth until
someone gets shot or do they Dan
Harmon's issue is that reality
shattering plot reveals and stories have
become such a worn out trope inserted
into movies and TV shows just to blow
our minds when really they're just there
to make the audience feel stupid like a
lot of these plot twists don't do
anything to further character along they
just reveal a master plotter whether
it's Danny ocean or Mysterio or Rick to
really just be a weird sociopathic
genius who wastes everyone's time with
lies when they could just steal what
they want but by the end of this episode
we learned that there's a deeper agenda
behind Rick's heist mean when that is
purely selfish he orchestrates all the
twists and turns of this plot in order
to make Morty just unenthusiastic about
Morty's own heist movie script that he
plans to pitch to Netflix the inception
idea and Morty's mind so that Morty will
give up on his own pitch not pursue his
Hollywood dreams and stay with Rick
so that Rick won't be alone because we
know at the end of last episode the old
mainland seat and Rick's loneliness is a
very big deal
this old Netflix subplot almost
certainly came from the writers on
Harmon and roylene's writing team it's
kind of an insider joke in the TV and
film industry that Netflix is producing
a ton of content and they'll greenlight
literally anything and likely many of
the writers Harmon and Roland have
worked with have been offered similar
Netflix deals actually the writer of
that community conspiracy theory episode
I mentioned Chris McKenna end up leaving
Harmons team to pursue a very successful
career as a Hollywood screenwriter and
what was his most recent success
spider-man far from home a movie filled
with the bonkers
the ice twist at this episode mocks add
that to the fact that Harmons go to
community directors were Joe and Anthony
Russo who went on to direct Winter
Soldier Civil War infinity war and in
game so is it too much of an armchair
reach to suggest that Harman may feel
left behind in a creative industry that
takes in profits with the kind of
storytelling that he considers hackery
I don't know however personal this may
be it is at least fair to say that this
episode is hiding a deeper plot to
reprogram Rick and Morty fans to think
that everything else we like is hackery
and bad writing so that we see only Rick
and Morty as good writing a master class
on how jokes should be structured how
stories should be told and how
characters should grow but really it's
just a cry for help to do less alone but
hey that's just my explanation in my own
wrong son of a [ __ ] is the MCU actually
flawless in every possible way well
stick around because we're gonna dive
deeper into this episode with special
guests after a brief message from our
sponsors hey guys have you ever been so
self-conscious about smelling good when
you go out that rather than hopelessly
wander the aisles of a department store
you wait till you get a rideshare that
smells kind of good and roll around in
the backseat until your drive drops you
off early I have smelling good is
important and that's why I love
Hawthorne instead of inhaling the
perfume inserts of old catalogs like an
insane person Hawthorne has you take a
short quiz about your lifestyle and
preferences and then they send you to
scents one for work and one for play and
they offer this handy quiz that I loved
with a scale for Bo that goes from no Bo
too painful Bo and painful can apply to
the emotional pain you feel when a
bouncer stops you at the door and tells
you because of the way you smell they no
longer fear hell they also have
deodorant shampoo and body wash the
whole process is easy and convenient
best of all it's totally risk-free with
free shipping and free returns check out
Hawthorne at Hawthorne Co that's
Hawthorne with Annie and use my promo
code Ric to get 10% off your first
purchase
that's H a wth o R in Y Co use my code
Ric to get 10% off your purchase
Hawthorne co support for explained also
comes her a manscaped
the best and men's below-the-belt
grooming manscaped offers precision
engineered tools for your family jewels
it's time to gear up and get yourself
the gift of Shaving this holiday season
and I'm talking about the manscape
perfect package 2.0 holiday sweaters
might be itchy and furry but you don't
need to be
that's why manscaped has redesign
the electric trimmer their lawnmower 2.0
has proprietary advanced skin-safe
technology so this trimmer won't Nick or
snag your nuts it's also waterproof so
you can use it in the shower or he'll
take in the pool with you when you say
milli Kalikimaka with Danny Griswold in
that new pool he built for you put the
jelly of the Month Club certificate the
lawnmower 2.0 comes inside their perfect
package 2.0 which makes the perfect gift
this holiday season it literally
everything you need to keep trimmed cut
free and smell them nice down there
the manscape perfect package 2.0
includes the crop preserver and a crop
Reviver to keep your balls from sweat
and smelling and sticking and these
products melt in the words of cousin
Eddie good good and their manly scent is
attractive and will set the mood if you
know what I mean get 20% off and free
shipping with the code were explained at
manscape comm that's 20% off with free
shipping and manscaped comm when he used
the code or explained you can be a bad
santa without being a bushy santa and
we're back to discuss this episode with
us the one crew over the crew cooze
Morty - I get it yeah are some special
guests friends to the show comedian and
host of the new player has joined
podcast here on our starburns Network
Jeff sieh Neil thank you for coming to
the show Jeff absolutely and as always
comedian - Rick and Morty superfan and
hyster of my heart Tommy back told they
shaved me they shaved me they shaved my
beard it's gone we we got some
complaints from the advertisers big
beard just didn't want to have my face
with a beard on it anymore
yeah well earlier in this episode which
you guys weren't here for I was by
myself so you have no idea what I talked
about I I went into how it's not just
about Rick's hatred of heist movies
which Dan Harmon has admitted he hates
the heist genre and these tropes of
reveals and twists in double crossings
it's also about the Marvel fan base
right because the past two Marvel films
the the biggest movies of the year
Avengers in game
spider-man apart from home both high
stories that have these big twisty
reveals and and we know Dan Harmon has
his history with the MCU in his
consultation dr. strange and he got a
joke in this episode that is a direct
reference to his experience on Doctor
Strange so like do we think what what is
his whole beef with the Marvel fan base
and just fan bases in general I mean I
think it's everything like I was gonna
get all the noise in but
yeah I mean I I think that he is a
person that feels personally offended by
kind of patronizing storylines like yes
like it's like like if you're doing
something formulaic or if you're doing
something that he perceives as lazy it
like really bothers him out of this oral
level yeah and fortunately for him he
has a multi-million dollar cartoon that
he can use as an outlet to express that
instead of you know going to like a fan
blog and post Mad posting just watch him
shout from a rooftop and he happens to
have the loudest megaphone available I
can't say like even I disagree with him
whenever he does something it's so funny
that episode was one of the funnier
episodes ahead in a while and that's
saying something because they're all
generally pretty funny yeah yeah but the
jokes were just so smart yeah there's so
many like twists and they keep pulling
up they keep pulling out the rug from
underneath it's like how far along did
you guys get before he stopped even
trying to follow the logic of the twist
oh yeah I tried to last yeah right up to
the end of that back two-thirds in and I
was like I get it I'm just along for the
ride write the joke becomes that we're
making the joke it was like hey man you
do you I'm happy every time that like
techno music would hit that
now we're gonna explain how this all
happened I just thought yeah it'll help
some small phrase using the monotone you
son of a [ __ ] it reminded me a lot of
the sequence in macGruber which is my
favorite they put the team together
immediately dies and like they just did
that on repeat this whole yeah it's
interesting how this episode did have a
lot of like inside baseball kind of
jokes like the whole idea of a Netflix
deal I wonder how many of Rick and Morty
fans understand like the deeper truth of
what yeah it is a very attainable goal
they even had like the exterior side of
the sunset and Bronson's videos like
that actually looks at the beginning of
the episode the concept of getting a
professional badge and a
comic book yeah which is like it's one
of those things that in the industry
you're like you're you crave the
professional badge because it somehow
makes you feel just a little bit better
than the people who spent you know a few
hundred ollars on the badge yet you're
all doing the same thing oh yeah we
mention all the buy toys meant for
children for hundreds of dollars whether
it says professional or amateur or toy
enthusiast or pervert yes yeah Rick's
pride that he will not pay for a badge
he's so insulted that morning even
suggested you have to heist your way in
there right it honestly is like I mean
we've been to cons before I've gone to
VidCon and in LA comic-con and like the
first year I went to VidCon we were like
we had just broken like a million
subscribers to your star to have like an
ego and the fact that like VidCon we
didn't they didn't give a [ __ ] about me
rock stars at that time I had to walk
around with just like the red badge and
it's Walker and on VidCon and having
people look at me be like our convention
is just the smartest and most expensive
way to form in-group out-group that
we've ever come up with oh yeah okay
they're complete it's a giant cafeteria
in a middle school yeah it's the
funniest thing to have the badge and be
like I made it and then show up at the
same bar where the people who don't in
the bed should be like hello I will pay
the same price for that your night will
also pay $14
[Laughter]
I'm a professional so by like dissing
what they perceive to be inferior
storytelling styles reminded me also of
that South Park episode that went after
Family Guy right because they're going
after other fan things that normally
people are kind of okay with are they
like like I think it's okay to like the
MCU in heist movies yeah we were talking
about this before it's like despite
these scathing and I believe correct
indictments on the genre I still love
those movies yeah like I'm still big fan
of heist movies they're fun whether or
not they're there enlightening in any
way is kind of irrelevant for me I'm not
watching them to really learn about
oh no the art of hoisting know one of
the greatest shames of my life was
watching the entirety of now you see me
and going that was okay out of it I'm
sure of Dan Harmon sees this he'll think
less of me but the truth of who I am
yeah is it okay to like these things
like they don't follow the same
story beats that Rick and Morty episodes
do but like there's even get catharsis
so see Danny ocean screw-up or Terry
Benedict why not yes
the thing is like these it's fun to
watch the movies and it's fun to watch
the takedown the movies and if somebody
were able to do a takedown of Rick and
Morty I would enjoy watching it too the
problem is Dan Harmon just happens to be
the best in the gaming these takedowns
yeah so the funniest voice is gonna be
the one that I get beyond ego I mean I
feel like Trey Parker could do it like
with the news of the South Park but I I
don't think you would want to I think he
probably respects what Rick and I would
hate to back and forth like why are we
doing 20 candidate Democrat debates
right now CNN hit behind putting these
two in a little comedic mutually assured
destruction so do we think it's petty
for like Rick and Morty to do episodes
to give whole episodes like this or
should TV shows be doing this more well
Rick is the pettiest character I'm
telling ya sure there's that it's
completely it's completely honest yeah I
think I think it's authentic to them it
doesn't feel generous it's something
they've earned you know yeah something
they've earned through all of these
seasons to do an episode like this that
again I don't want to steal from you we
talked about before
is kind of devoid of a B story yeah it's
something you have to kind of earn yeah
and they have we watched it without
really caring like I never thought what
what is what is uh what are the other
characters doing where's Mort especially
up to you know yeah I find it hard to
care about Jerry when you've got what is
it was the truculent on Titanic and how
like goofy yeah structure is are there
other like film genres or fan cultures
that you wish they would go after like
they have for this episode well you know
I think ones on Raw that gets kind of in
my opinion a free pass always as like
you know like the worse it is is often
better to horror movies well yeah well
people like bad horror isn't itself an
art form like b-movie horror is like
people defend it to the death like
people will tell you oh you've got to
watch like red man
it's like 1985 it's the budget was
negative $3 and like three people died
on the shoe you can only see it at 1
a.m. at this one theater on Wilshire you
gotta say a code you will get knifed
people have been going for six years
like III would be interesting to see his
take on like very like mid-level budget
horror movies that we all just seemingly
go no matter what these are fine yeah
it's hard they're unassailable yeah I
think he could do it
I like the I would say I'd like to see
them do a takedown of just multicam
sitcoms almost the way that it's always
sunny day but like in the the
transdimensional cable episode I feel
like I got little pieces of that here
and there and they got a lot of
different TV genres in sure so like
listen if you do it intelligently and if
you have a good point even if it's not
like this you should stop watching this
I'm like yep I just realized the always
sunny guys could be like the alan yang
of the debate like they could come in as
kind of like the Andrea Andrea yes
Andrea they can be like the Andrew yang
character candidate like they could just
come in and just throw out crazy yeah
yeah but only speak for like a minute of
it and yeah yeah yeah so let's talk
about like what's coming next the the
post-credits scene of this episode was
like seeing dark storm clouds on the
horizon that's fun like mr. Poirot
reflecting on like the layers Rick must
have gone to to stage this whole heist
do we think that like they say it might
be a twister it's like maybe another
twist episode like the next episode
titles are claw and hoarder special
victims Morty and that's in two weeks oh
my god so next week followed by the
season 5 or season 4 mid-season premiere
or finale rattle star Rick lactic ax so
which episode do you think this might be
foreshadowing and what do you think it
is what's the darkness on horizon man I
don't
before even touching that great job that
they ruined it mr. poo buttholes life
for a second time it's just accidentally
like here's your existence we're gonna
shoot that to the sides it's job
whatever I can never this is one of the
few shows where it's like I rarely
see the twist ones coming and I'm
delighted whenever it shows up yeah so
like I don't know if there's a
Battlestar Gallactica episode on the you
know in the horizon I hope it's for that
I hope it all builds to that because
there's so much to love about Battlestar
Galactica and there's so much to hate
about yeah so if they're gonna you know
keep taking [ __ ] down never seen it
before
yeah the more the more they can they can
put off to that last episode if it's all
building to something I trust them I
love it I hope it all falls down
hilariously yeah that's all well I hope
so too well thank you guys so much again
for joining us on this this episode of
Rick's Lane again special thanks to a
comedian and host of the podcast new
player has joined Jesse Neil amazing oh
and Tommy thanks for saving my apologies
to Andrew yang yang gang if you're gonna
give that thousand out don't skip my
house baby do you say that the end of
every episode because if you haven't you
just need to start and the reminder is
always to subscribe to our Rick's plane
podcast feed to get audio versions of
all this stuff earlier than the YouTube
versions that will come out and
subscribe to us on all social media
YouTube Twitter Facebook yeah we got
everything for everything you probably
me a TA box and and of course out this
episode let's throw to our favorite joke
this episode
[Music]